i've got some really good news for you
if you want to make threats against
russians on social media you know
threats on social media against anybody
are generally frowned upon except right
now facebook has just declared that you
now can allow for posts uh threatening
violence against russians specifically
with regard to ukraine
so this change in policy
just came out from meta platforms it
will allow facebook and instagram users
in certain countries to call for
violence against russians and russian
soldiers in the context of the ukraine
invasion now you can't call for violence
against russians if you say for instance
i ate my borscht tonight and some of the
red beet juice splattered on my blazer
i'm going to kill you russians that is
not allowed but you can say hey i really
like ukraine i want to kill you russians
that is totally fine you've got to be
very specific about what kind of threats
of violence you're making against the
russian people this is according to
internal emails that were seen by
reuters last thursday
this is a temporary change to its hate
speech policy facebook instagram all the
social media companies have hate speech
policies
and the point of these policies is that
hate will not be tolerated unless mark
zuckerberg wants to tolerate it
hate will not be tolerated on the
platform except when zuckerberg deems it
right
there's a another change that took place
on facebook with regard to ukraine
specifically one of the groups that is
fighting in ukraine is a neo-nazi group
it's called the azov battalion there are
lots of different military and
paramilitary groups fighting in ukraine
but one of them is a neo-nazi group
called the asoc battalion you were not
permitted to
support the azov battalion on facebook
that previously violated its hate speech
policy now temporarily during the war in
ukraine you are allowed to make
supportive comments of the neo-nazi
group because that neo-nazi group is
fighting against the russians now by the
way
i totally understand
why depending on the context
facebook would change this hate speech
policy
i totally understand why they might say
that in some cases it's okay to make
comments in support of nazis and calling
for violence against the russians don't
forget in world war ii we teamed up with
russian communists we in the united
states timed up with teamed up with
russian communists to fight the nazis
the communists are no better than the
nazis but the united states determined
it was in our geopolitical interest to
defeat nazi germany so the way to do it
was to team up with the russian
communists we did that
and then immediately after the second
world war we started another war with
communist russia
that went on and that was called the
cold war so i can understand how in this
case they say look
right now
you got to put your issues with the
nazis aside we've got to team up with
the nazis to fight
the russians who are increasingly
looking like the exact same old russian
communists who were fighting in the cold
war okay
the question for me is
do we trust big tech with this power
if we are going to say that certain
things are going to be censored certain
speech is going to be encouraged even
certain
hate speech is going to be encouraged
even certain direct calls for violence
are going to be encouraged even certain
defenses of neo-nazis are going to be
encouraged now do we trust big tech to
make that call
i don't
certainly not
do we trust big tech not to use this
exact same power this exact same kind of
capriciousness
to say
okay now we're going to look at domestic
politics now that we're done dealing
with the nazis in ukraine and the
communists in russia now we're going to
look at those nazis in america you know
those january 6th people
do we not do we not believe that
facebook and youtube and twitter and
google
do we really think they wouldn't use
this power against us to say actually
it's okay to call for certain violence
against certain groups here in america
actually okay it's fine to support
certain violent hate groups here in
america they already do that it's fine
to support antifa it's fine to support
blm antifa and blm spent eight months
burning the country down in 2020.
it's fine to support them
and by the way it's basically tolerated
to to
threaten conservatives on twitter
maybe it's technically against the
letter of the law but rarely will people
get in trouble
for
for defaming insulting even threatening
conservatives who the left believes are
deplorable and irredeemable do we trust
these guys
to have this power i certainly do not
i'm so glad you like that clip now
please ring the bell subscribe maybe
leave a comment head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n-w-l-e-s
s-h-o-w leave a five-star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you